I wasn't always very excited about math.
I was more excited about reading novels, and
I thought I would become a writer one day.
I got excited about it maybe just as a challenge,
but then I realized that it's really nice
and that I enjoy it.
These were quite difficult times.
It was during the war.
Right after the war, I had a lot of opportunities.
I went to a very good middle school and then
high school.
I think I was the lucky generation because
I was a teenager when things became more stable.
My main interest is understanding structures
you can put on a surface.
There are different ways of looking at it.
Either you have a surface with some additional
geometric structures, or these kinds of problems
are related to understanding the space of
such structures.
One very famous example is if you have a billiard
table and you start from from a point and
you hit the ball and it hits the boundaries
and it moves forever, you want to see the
trajectory of the ball.
Would it cover all your billiard table?
Can you find closed billiard paths and interestingly
enough, this is an open question in general,
if you don't put any restrictions on angles
of the polygon that you started.
There are two types of questions.
One is: You have a surface with a geometric
structure, and you're trying to understand
some properties of the geometric structure
that you have.
The other questions are related to: You have
a surface, and you have a geometric structure
and you start deforming this geometric structure.
And then you want to see what kind of surfaces
you would get.
Some of the problems like, you know the properties
of a generic surface, a random surface.
But it's really hard to say something about
a single given geometric structure on the
surface.
Some of the work that I've done with different
collaborators shows that sometimes a surface
is very to one of a generic surface.
You can ask these questions about hyperbolic
surfaces or these flat surfaces or different
geometric structures.
I think these problems are important because
they are related to some other problems.
Even if you are interested in high-dimensional
manifolds, one way of dealing with them is
trying to find some nice surface inside of
them.
You end up learning a lot about other spaces
and properties of other action, so it give
you a lot of information.
It's not only the question, but the way you
try to solve it.